Welcome to dinner for all the teams
who have to play on Thanksgiving!
I brought my famous green bean casserole
It’s pretty good, but it’s not gonna win any awards
I wish we could go out to the bar
tonight like the other teams
ELI, IT’S BEEN YEARS!
HOW YOU BEEN, MAN?!
We’re undefeated in November!
YO, JAMES CONNER IS DOING KARAOKE!
We’ve got some exciting news in the middle
of this Gridiron Heights episode
PS4 and VR Bundles are starting at $199
during Black Friday week!
GOBBLE, GOBBLE
Taysom, more pepper!
Hey man, let me take that
I think you’re finished
Pass this around to Khalil
Just pass left, Mitchell
A toast!
We may not see all of you next year—
Wait, what?
But we love coming together
To friendly competition!
Careful, Matt, don’t choke
WHERE’S DREW’S MVP, SEAN?!
SIT UP STRAIGHT
BE FANCY AND PROFESSIONAL LIKE ME
Hey, Stafford, you want seconds?
Uh, sure
I’m Colt McCoy
and I’m still the most popular quarterback in Texas
THE NFC EAST COULD BE MINE
INTERCEPTION
I BLAME THE FANS
TAYSOM, START THE CAR
Already done, sir
Hey, what exactly is Taysom Hill’s job?
NOBODY KNOWS
I could kick Dan Quinn’s ass
I’m good now
Happy Thanksgiving